the Joe Rogan experience are these
[ __ ] are these nails no those are
wild boars tusks yeah Wow put my buddy
Adam green tree same guy who shot that
thing he gave me those have you ever
slain a boar yeah you have yeah yeah
there that to hone ranch place have
hunted them a couple times out there
they're interesting how's the meat it's
very good yeah what's weird though is we
were in the we were walking down this
trail and we heard them fighting in the
bushes and if you didn't know any better
you like they didn't had no idea we were
there you would think they're demons
they were going to war with each other
oh it sounded horrible yeah it's a
horrible sound don't worry you'll never
be on the field oh [ __ ] you up man yeah
Wow pigs will [ __ ] you up
yes Harry yes they will yeah so that's
that's a old boars tusks that's what
that is
yeah dude hey man we got so let you
drink black coffee you are rugged no no
no hey just got a point no I'm a rugged
boy ever now I went out walking buddy
back yard once a good [ __ ] way into
the woods a little bit and we've stayed
there and then out of nowhere this old
lady was like can you guys keep it down
and were like who the [ __ ] that until
this day I think it was a ghost you know
you should do actually Oh [ __ ] I
wish you go hunting you come you you
stay at the campfire you great show yeah
you should be you should be waiting for
us when we come back with a pair of the
meal that's right
so you be our guy and you can shave down
after we eat I'm not gonna shave let me
finish
after you shaved down you make us a meal
and afterwards we [ __ ] you in the wild
nobody's looking but no they got [ __ ]
camera
their brow they probably do now
[Applause]